peu du fait qu'on soit limitrophes avec
une autre commune dix jeunes attachés à
la casse m on a la possibilité de
demander notre ancien viola qu'ancienne
ça ne se fait pas comme ça du jour au
lendemain je ne suis pas assez
satisfaisants une mandature
je l'espère en tout cas mais je pense
que le groupe va bénéficier de beaucoup
de choses
si nous sommes attachés à la personne
aujourd'hui nous sommes branchés les
petits je vous ferai un petit chez lego
et ensuite qu'est ce que j'ai à voir ce
que logona à voir avec caen b avec
quatre pilotes avec deux par mois
le coût cher j'aime beaucoup seul un ado
j'aime ces communes là mais je pense que
le gaumont à sa place dans central ou
court central avec la casse m